you know it's it is interesting because
that I've I've heard variations on that
argument you know a fair amount that say
you know these Technologies like social
media was were supposed to connect us
they can allow us to be constantly
connected and you know some people have
said well you know if gen Z is spending
a lot of time on social media and online
they're mostly communicating with their
friends who cares you know that's the
same thing that that young people have
always done they're just doing it in a
different way through a different medium
but one way to answer that question
about does it matter and who cares is to
say what's the link to happiness what's
the link to mental health and as social
media became more popular as more people
got smartphones that's exactly when we
saw these very large increases in
anxiety and depression and self harm and
even suicide among young adults and
adolescents